the Press of paparazzi's you know they
want to get the right shot they want to
get the right story but Public Safety
must always be at the Forefront of my
The Briefing I received you know two of
our offices could have been injured New
York City is different
from a small town somewhere you
shouldn't be speeding anywhere but this
is a densely populated city and I think
all of us I don't think there's many of
us who don't recall how
how the his mom died and it would be
horrific to lose the innocent bystander
during a chase like this and something
to have happened to them as well I would
find it hard to believe that there was a
two-hour high-speed chase that would be
finding it hard to believe but we will
find out the exact duration of it but if
it's uh 10 minutes a 10 minute Chase is
extremely dangerous in New York City we
have a lot of traffic a lot of movement
a lot of people are using our streets of
any type of high-speed chase that
involves something of that nature is
inappropriate